okay babe it's a boy psychobabble and
looks like we're back
wait is this thing even working Co I'm
home okay yeah right go we're going back
in this is gonna be scary I know it okay
it just never gets easy okay
that's that party I like worried a lot
huh
I met that configure something huh okay
but yeah okay okay here we go
I don't know why I let myself cry it oh
my god disgusting okay there's three of
them but they don't even look related
okay yeah kind of let's say any exit
this okay oh this is without the blood
rose it says miniatures do I always have
to find difference what is that
I don't know what that is and I don't
care to find out
I said fire or something over there
I love it where it's in here oh my god
Dara it is baby Dara des I said my god
what's gonna happen now
what is that
why is that noise
and I want that noise us it's ours
playing something
[ __ ] hair burn and then the sunlight
why is it kind of so for the birds
okay again
ouch okay that's gonna stop rattling
again
I guess they gotta go upstairs and
classifies drive-bys this thing is like
socratic that let's say okay now now now
all right we'll say what's going on I
guess I'll say what's going on fellas
yeah hey this place is gonna go for
peeing in here where are all these paper
works nothing down there
I feel like have like an ant on my neck
I do have an ant on my neck
the things you said crash okay let's do
this the AI testing room again there's
nothing in that room I know there's
nothing in there I'm just gonna leave it
open
I'm gonna close it I just Steven
analyzing previous legend operation I
think the problems connected with Europe
its connect to a block see what more
time word but you can family come back
when you're smeared Abraham okay and
that thing there should be two more toys
right accorded that picture a lot of
jump scares so I'm kind of freaked out
about then have it on this one okay so
don't disturb nobody close it yep
who's that noise
did I like miss something I feel like
that's everything now they change that
[Music]
Warners to 30 stabbed once while the
child was two days later strangled in
his sleep okay yeah you check my office
one more time last time there was like
more stuff Oh
era patient 41
I've been acquainted with a traumatic in
these past life violence in the family
and pathology I've decided that I will
use a less invasive method of treatment
mm-hmm we can handle without hypnosis
the confrontation hurts me that the can
think this in a while anxiolytics at
would be enough I think that finishing
the dream so killing the wife and child
can join his foot cells all we need to
do is wait and observe
what is that noise so
like flies in there doing all right so
and this is where the creepy stuff goes
it's just gonna go crazy in a second oh
so we'll move this this was definitely
not moved before so we're gonna hear it
as a way to quiet there it's gonna be a
jump scare for sure for sure
there we go I've got hair cast
Cystic to the ball psychobabble just
stick to the wall oh my god oh my god
what's in here yeah we got it baby we
got what we came here for
it says Tess carrot oh oh my god I did
not like that creepy we got one more
figure right
[Music]
okay can I just go in the back room do I
got a sign in on something all right God
bad vice is I don't know what that is
tank so the gardener like went and
smashed up what
so we have them all now this is what I'm
gonna get it really bad
oh great oh crap
everything gone crazy now everything
gone crazy
yep can't even move that fast okay well
I'm not even moving it's doing it for me
huh
right behind oh I don't know mrs. Cole
on its way
what is with the crows okay so the
gardener dad didn't did do it dad what
is going on here
now that suggests crazy as I look behind
right
am i in a bed oh no I mean they could
carriage and how about they get SEC
motion sickness as heck
okay I'm the crow again but take super
dark hello crap I don't know why how
does it what
why but now here grateful for what I've
done for you if I provided substance for
this whole house what the heck is this
had lightened
okay so let's tackle this garden house
first hey back Harry
Oh am I now any other gardener I got the
duckie mission accomplished
what did that sound crazy going on there
that like safe to walk there I feel like
meddling should not Joyride like that
that's sad sit yeah definitely was that
safe to walk there definitely was not
safe to add there anyway let me get that
ducky again Jess okay that's a internal
oh I gotta turn the car lights on so I
can blanch the lightning okay I gotta
get this duck again okay I got the ducky
you had to figure out a way to like turn
on this car looks broken
okay so I could get like tape or
something and then I can turn on the car
and that will turn on the light and then
I can go in there and then I could get
the job done you know and I call that
day's work but uh let's go that's right
guys man think I walk so slow so slow
just disheartening how slaughtered and
why's this it's very nice very nice what
they did so you get the harnesses never
locked ordinary I start were terribly
but blah Eddie
he's actually crazy
oh we smoked that let's get the heck out
of me okay well I can go this way but I
already have the tape to fix it
man that ain't got man that any guy hey
hey really needed more money you know
that's what happens if any pegar type
you know kayo enough they dark going
horizon and they start thinking about as
to murder our family something that's
really gonna be careful no wait Carol
these lights
it just seems disgusting on there huh
yeah I go okay the lights are on let's
do this moves out go muchachos that's
the word I was looking for okay what's
up there what is this this is disgusting
oh sorry mr. Huck what is that Dibble
buried in the garden he was killed was
strangled
yes cut that out
okay look at this last area today
and I can't the find that some Greg I
kept that okay let's just it doesn't
grow on trees okay can you cut that out
I thought I thought you what's in there
Zach it's so quiet
okay let's see here pan out okay yeah
great great going great just what I
wanted
what's in here no that's cuz of the
basement I can can I go in this water no
I can't
nice bits
[Music]
thank goodness is low linear otherwise
it was too when I'd be like going crazy
Crabbe set thought out once you get the
ducky that's when we like things start
going crazy I know there's death the
mother unforgiving crows
animal psychology every morning two
crows thought and memory release and fly
by the world
[Music]
where's anything over here
it's closed off this room it's College
accused by the critics
there we go
[Music]
oh so basically what happened is his
stories like this guy like getting
confirm his guy he was a famous
psychiatrist or psychologist and he had
a wife and kid and they had a gardener
and the gardener got jailed for slipping
her love the wife and then went to go
kill the wife and get killed the wife
stabbed three times back two days later
strangled the boy the guy's been like
crazy depressed and he has essentially
been using his a controversial treatment
which he's already bun up in trouble
with it on herself
[Music]
data today is 22 March March
only experiment I do not like how are
you
this hotels are my jokes okay so this is
one thing so crazy saying well I know
the phone is at least it's a way to
quiet which means this give me a jump
scare don't even lock down that hallway
Donovan looks like how about you I know
I know I don't even lock your luck
straight down okay oh I gotta hate that
spanning can't watch phone just right
just right come on Deborah go alright go
let's go let's go
okay well I live it there until next
time with ChaCha's until next time wait
what is this actually it's fortunate
cool
I miss the end Wow it's like out I said
I was walking toast law in the game so
they men make it even slower
[Music]
so on Thursday day you visited while dr.
madam
[Music]
Baxter Dam
[Music]
Sunday morning he's hot dog see doctor
was right
what marshmallows is that yell I might
have had and until next time brass